Looking at myself,
honestly,
John says,
I'm deeply envious and resentful of others happiness.
How do I turn this around?
Where all John,
I would say you've started to turn it down around already because you have at
least come to the conclusion that you're deeply envious and resentful of others
happiness.
So you did have the damn problem diagnosed.
So one of the things you might do is figure out what you would like instead.
Like how would you like to feel about the world,
you know,
because you're implying that being deeply envious and resentful isn't for the
best.
So let's assume that you would rather be pleased about other people's successes
and not envious.
Well,
you know,
the first thing you might think is,
well maybe you have to do some writing or at least some thinking.
It's like maybe the alternative would be happy,
be happy about other's success and happiness.
Well maybe you should start by thinking about why you might be happy about their
happiness.
It's not like happiness is a zero sum game,
you know,
it's not like it's not.
And I believe me,
I'm taking your question seriously and I think that what you're saying
characterized as plenty of people and I think that you're being deeply honest,
noticing it,
happiness isn't a zero sum game.
You know,
lots of people can be happy at the same time.
And do you really want to live in a world where other people are less happy in
what possible manner would that be useful and good for you in the medium to
longterm?
It might make you feel,
you know,
grudgingly a satisfied,
in a dark way temporarily,
but it's not a very good long term strategy.
So I would say you got to think it through,
you know,
what,
how is it that you would like to view the world?
How do you think that would be best for you?
I mean as if you were taking care of yourself like you,
like you're someone who deserves to be taken care of.
Think about how you'd like to have the world,
how he'd like to view the world.
And one of the ways you can do that too,
is to think about some people that you admire and try to figure out how they
look at the world or even ask them,
you know,
because maybe then you can find out what it is about your thought patterns that
are driving you down.
This sort of dark road.